welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and of all the lingering mysteries
from Avengers endgame one stands out
from the rest who is new master 69 I
know you're thinking just throwaway joke
meant to show Thor's pathetic bachelor
lifestyle but no it's not nothing is
throwaway everything matters and just
like not Gwen Stacy and floki nor in
gorg's fortnight enemy must be a
disguised Easter egg that will have some
greater significance any future MCU film
if it doesn't they are wasting a huge
opportunity for interconnectivity but I
really do think Marvel will revealed new
master 69 is someone that we know and
that they might have already told us who
it is
I'm gonna break down all the evidence so
let's start with the moment that new
master 69 entered our lives Hulk and
Rocket visited backdoor Korg and meek in
their Norway bachelor pad Thor he's back
that kid on the TV just called me a dick
it again new master hey lor again you
know the god of thunder listen buddy if
you don't log off this game immediately
I'm gonna fly over to your house come
down to that basement you're hiding in
rip off your arms and shove them up your
butt cried you Bobby a little weasel
that's so we can narrow down our
possible suspects by looking at a few
things we know about new masters 69 so
new master 69 obviously a gamer and new
master 69 obviously a troll he is a
bully who targets the weak so who else
is a gamer in them see you well Groot
obviously he's a teenager
he loved his games but he's obviously
currently a pile of dust in this moment
also korgoth or probably would have to
hear I am Groot
as there's also that SHIELD
agent from the Helicarrier in the first
Avengers that man is playing Galaga
whether that guy survived and whether
he's still shield or Hydra operative he
could now I'll be trolling door there's
also comic relief characters like Darcy
Lewis from the Thor movies released from
the ant-man movies and some of us that
Deadpool would be a perfect candidate to
reveal as to Master 69 when he
inevitably joins cinematic universe but
we look even deeper at the evidence it
actually points to two people it's worth
noting that Thor and cord live in
tonsberg norway which is in a time zone
six hours ahead of the American Eastern
Standard Time
it looks as though it's morning when
whole can rocket visit so that would
mean if new masters American he or she
would be gaming in the late hours of the
night possibly between 3 and 6 a.m.
notice the exact words Thor used when he
threatened new master I'm gonna fly over
to your house come down to that basement
you're hiding in rip off your arms and
shove them up your butt go cry do you
Bobby a little weasel go cry to your
father so whom do we know in the MCU is
awake all hours of the night who is
suffering from major daddy issues Tony
my man Stark we know that around this
time he has been on an unusual sleep
schedule cracking time travel and
engineering the quantum wristwatch tech
we also know that he had been waiting
for Thor back at Avengers HQ ready to
mock the hell out of the god of thunder
one side there's a bow ski stark also
has serious daddy issues in endgame
later on he literally goes crying to his
father and finally there's the name new
masters 69 Stark in this movie loves
sneaking in 69 jokes not that it's a
competition but she loves me 3,000 who
does she know you were somewhere until
oh six to nine hundred branch so that
makes one good candidate for new masters
69 but there's still one more out there
another trolling bully with sophomoric
humor impossible daddy issues
flash my parents hate me Thompson as far
back as spider-man homecoming we know
that flash loves to bully people with
sexual degradation
and more recently in spider-man far from
home a series of background details
showed flash as estranged from his
parents a text message exchange showed
that he hadn't heard from his father in
days later his parents stranded him at
the airport
finally and far from home flash revealed
that the god of thunder pales in
comparison to other Avengers he's like
Iron Man and Thor rolled into one he's
no Spider Man
what is it with you and spider-man what
he looks out for the neighborhood has a
dope suit and I really respect him
sup dickwad ha ha more tick tocks more
Thor hating and he cries over his father
Flash Thompson even more than Tony Stark
might be the best MCU option for our new
master but sadly now that Tony's dead
and flash has been banished to the Sony
verse along with all the other
spider-man properties cord may never
hear from new masters 69 again do you
think Tony or flash is more likely to be
new master 69 and if neither of those
who do you think it is
comment down below with your thoughts
follow me on instagram and twitter at EA
vas subscribe to new rock stars for
breakdown to theories of everything
marvel thank you for joining me I've
been Eric 3 me from this blue dungeon
boss
[Music]